compressions de dépenses hausses de
certaines taxes du tabac de l'alcool en
particulier les frais de garderie qui un
peu plus tôt prévu augmenteront un
budget sévère même si monsieur le
ministre carlos leitao bonsoir bonsoir
même si vous vous refusez le terme
austère mais c'est quand même assez
austère merci je l'écouté je pense pas
avec un des dépenses 11,5 milliards en
infrastructures
je vois pas où est la vérité là où nous
sommes très rigoureux cédant le contrôle
d'augmentation du rythme de dépenses de
programmes sa wii nous allons bien les
maîtriser bien les contrôler pour nous
pour s'assurer que nous arrivons en
équilibre budgétaire dans deux ans vous
avez quand même laissé tomber une
promesse puis ça a été soulignée très
rapidement dans le budget c'est 1,5
milliard supplémentaire que vous deviez
que vous vouliez que vous plaît dit que
c'était nécessaire de mettre en
infrastructures vous dites est ce que
simplement vous dites on n'a pas les
moyens
notre dette serait insoutenable c'est
essentiellement ça tout à fait ce que ce
que nous nous le constatons c'est que le
déficit en 2013 14 l'année qui est
derrière nous et est après tour de 3,1
milliards de dollars
quand on regarde et nous la préparation
de nos plans de campagne ont exposé être
à zéro c'est pas héros sétois régulier
en milliards par la suite cette année
c'est 2,3 5
donc vous voyez qu'ils sont entrain de
déjà à 5,5 milliards et demi de plus
alors avec une économie aussi qui a un
taux de croissance très la 2013 c'était
une année assez difficile
alors ce n'était pas vraiment le moment
nécessaire de le moment approprié pour
une telle chose même si j'étais eux je
vous y attends excusez moi mais là
dessus et puis on va passer à autre
chose après je vous ai entendu dire est
le premier lycée également aux réponses
du parti québécois qui vous demandait
d'enlever sa vous disiez non non non ça
va stimuler l'économie
il ya des projets cd job c'est des
emplois pour les québécois
donc en trois jours qu'est ce qui est
arrivé on vous a menacé d'une décote
tout quoi absolument pas ce que ce qu'on
avait dit ce qu'on dit toujours c'est
que cette année 2014 2015
les investissements n'a pas su se sont
sont sont substantielles 11,25 milliards
cccc beaucoup de sous donc ça nous nous
maintenons le cap pour cette année pour
les années subséquentes
on verra il y aura un nouveau plan
d'investissement voiture 2015-2025 qu'on
mettra en place l'année prochaine on
verra à ce moment-là sur pas accélérer
la cadence pour maintenant la réponse
est non pour maintenant on reste là donc
le poids de la dette vous inquiéter
vraiment considérablement
absolument on est rendu à 54 9 % du pib
c'est clair que avec la halle les 5
milliards il mixe se sont rajoutés à la
dette avec les deux années de déficit
quand on devrait être à zéro
ça limite notre notre champ d'action oui
mais je vous rappelle
vous parlez beaucoup en cours de 20 à 0
je vous rappelle monsieur météo que
était au pouvoir des libéraux 18 mois
avant le parti québécois
donc cette situation financière la est
hérité d'un gouvernement libéral ou ce
moment dans le nord
le dernier budget avant celui de
monsieur mario deux premiers de monsieur
marceau on avait un plan très concret
très gras d'être très réaliste de retour
équilibre budgétaire l'année 13 14 et l
année où selon le plan bacha on aurait
dû revenir avec elle et budgétaire et
même même oui mais je vais vous dire sur
marceau jusqu'à jusqu'à septembre 2013
nous disait non non non tout va bien on
va réussir et que les budgétaire s'est
depuis octobre 2013 tout en courbes ce
nom on n'est pas capable oui très bien
mené l'édition nos politiques n'ont pas
été prises non plus chez les libéraux
mais revenons à des choses là dans le
temps pour l'avenir vous étiez à des
compressions à chiffres absolus sur dans
treize ministères sur rennes 2 ça veut
dire quoi concrètement moins d'employés
moins de fonctionnaires moins de
programmes pour les citoyennes
ça veut dire moins de dépenses
poursuivre pour ces ministères là pour
l'instant tout ce qu'on a fait c'était
un gel des effectifs donc il n'y a
personne qui perd son emploi il n'y a
pas de mises à pied massives de la part
du gouvernement non ce qu'ont fait les
dépenses d'opération de ces ministères
là vont baisser
1/2 14000 15 la commande a été passée
tous les mystères ont leur cible de
dépenses et le conseil du trésor va
suivre ses cibles là de façon très très
stricte
je vous fais remarquer aussi monsieur
voir que ce type d'exercice ce fait se
faire maintenant et s'est fait récemment
dans les autres provinces canadiennes
je vois pas pourquoi nous maintenant au
québec on sait pas capable de vivre avec
une augmentation de 2 des programmes de
1,8 pour cent par année mais tout mais
dans les autres provinces canadiennes de
l'état aux dents certains aspects de la
vie à moins de programmes
gouvernementaux
donc vous dites parce que on ne peut pas
dire on va faire ça mais en ajoutant
toujours il n'y aura pas d'impact sur
les services aux citoyens
il y aura n'est pas que des choix à
faire tout à fait hier garde ya des
choix à faire et à l'intérieur de
l'appareil bureaucratique de leurs
intérêts des ministères le conseil du
trésor nous avons
un bon contrôle sur la façon dont les
ressources humaines sont distribués ce
qui nous manque un peu c'est ce même
type de contrôle dans les réseaux de la
santé et dans les réseaux de l'éducation
et c'est ce type de contrôle nous allons
chercher avec notre programme déjà les
effectifs et avec une loi qu'on va
passer à l'automne mais en est justement
être capable de préserver de livraison
de services
mais est-ce que vous financez
entièrement vos promesses en santé on
parlait de 50 clean et qu'on parlait de
2000 infirmières ça on va les voir ou si
vous oubliez ça ce soir on augmente hier
cet engagement là tout ne pourra pas se
faire d'un art jour évidemment mais
l'engagement est toujours là et pour
qu'on soit capable d'atteindre ces
objectifs là il fallait vraiment qu'on
aille chercher les outils nécessaires
pour gérer
l'appareil parapublic un nombre
d'employés a marre salariale c'est un
outil qui nous manquait est ce que vous
allez redoubler d'efforts pitch et que
vous le dit à chaque budget mais
beaucoup de gens disent oui mais il ya
de l'évasion fiscale encore trop ya
encore des gens qui créent des fiducie
familiale qui craint des des trucs des
fois lego lego des fois pas du tout est
ce que vous allez vous attaquer à ce que
tout le monde paie sa juste part tout à
fait écoutez le
revenu québec pas comme cible de
télévision fiscales cette année l'année
prochaine quand même des cibles
importantes de saint quelques millions
de dollars pour cette année le montant
total de récupération fiscale et aux
alentours de 3 8 milliards de dollars
c'est quand même substantielle et nous
allons continuer cet effort là
maintenant pour certaines des mesures
que vous venez de mentionner et d'autre
d'autres mesures sabran la coopération
la collaboration avec d'autres
gouvernements que ce soit le
gouvernement fédéral ou ce soit des
gouvernements étrangers nous subit nous
agissons dans l'intérieur de notre champ
de compétence de là nous faisons ce que
nous pouvons faire messieurs l'état dit
mot en terminant com quels mots vous
utiliseriez pour décrire la situation
avant votre budget vous êtes c'est très
grave c'est grave où vous vous êtes
arrivé à la conclusion que la situation
financière était en péril était non
contrôlée et aient été hors contrôle ça
serait ça le bourg qui ajouterait alors
nous nous arrivons et nous nous sommes
très sérieux dans notre approche
parce que situation était sérieuse donc
nous sommes sérieux nous allons
contrôler le rythme de dépenses de 2
rythme de croissance des dépenses vous
je vous dis que les par exemple le
gouvernement précédent
dans la première moitié de sa période de
gouvernance il aussi c'était très
sérieux ils ont de l'état on va laisser
faire le pq parce que dans la dernière
moitié du gouvernement charest aussi les
dépenses ont explosé également mais
parlons de l'avenir parce que oui soyons
justes le parti québécois est resté 18
mois au pouvoir bien deux grains période
des libéraux le port a pas pelleter par
un arrière
absolument pas mais si on faisait rien
le déficit de cette année serait de 5,9
milliards $ l'heure nous nous allons
contrôler ça et nous allons envoyer
aussi des signaux clairs que l'effort de
retour à l'équilibré jetair se fait du
coteau du côté des dépenses et non pas
du côté des revenus très bien il y
aurait d'autres questions montréalaise
parce que quand il ya des crédits
d'impôts qui touche la multimédia
vous avez baissé on aura des réactions
d'ailleurs après la pause on verra
comment tout ça va s'organiser tout le
monde doit faire sa part
merci les médecins aussi donc merci
arrive et bien sûr merci messieurs net
avant 20h par lenovo remercie